Sometimes we also consider query problems where we have a promise
on the input function, or in other words, some
sort of guarantee on it,
and we don't worry about functions that don't meet that promise.
Functions that don't satisfy the promise are considered as "don't care" inputs.
And we're just not responsible for what happens on those inputs.
Here's an example of a query problem with a promise called unique search.
It's related to the OR
problem, but it's different.
The input function has the same
form as for the OR problem, which is that it takes
n bits strings to bits.
This time, we're promised that
there's exactly one string Z that causes f to evaluate to 1,
with f of x being equal to 0
for every string x besides z, and the correct output
is this unique string z.
Of course, there are
choices for the function f that don't satisfy this condition, but we don't place any requirements at all
on algorithms for this problem when they're given such
functions as input.
We only care about the functions that do satisfy the promise.
Now, all four of the
problems I just mentioned are pretty natural problems, meaning that it's easy to explain them,
and it's easy to imagine situations in which a need to solve them might arise, but some query problems
aren't like this at all.
In fact, sometimes, we consider highly
contrived query problems, where it's difficult to imagine that anyone would ever
actually wanna solve them.
Simon's problem, which we'll
see later in the lesson, kind of falls into this category, but there are some other ones
that are much worse in some sense, but they, nevertheless, actually turn out to be pretty important to the study of the query model.
We don't study these problems because we necessarily want
to solve them in practice.
The way you can think about it is that we are looking for
extremes of various sorts,
in particular, when we're working within
this Petri dish of a model, a natural way to explore
quantum algorithmic ideas
is to formulate highly-contrived problems, where we can best exploit the
power of quantum computers.
And this can actually
shed a great deal of light on how quantum computers
can potentially be useful in more practical settings.
We can formalize the notion
of a query in different ways depending on what computational
model we're working with.
For example, in the Turing
machine model of computation, which we haven't talked about and we won't get into in this series,
there's a certain way of
formalizing the notion of a query that makes sense for that model.
For circuit models, we define special types of
gates called query gates, and that's how queries
are formally represented.
For Boolean circuits, there's a very simple way of doing this, which is simply to imagine
that we have query gates
that evaluate the input function directly, like you can see here on the screen.
The idea is that we can
use these query gates to build circuits that solve whatever
problem we're looking at,
and in order to work correctly, the circuits have to give the right answer for whatever input function f is given,
assuming that it meets the promise in the case of a promise problem.
Here's a simple example
of a Boolean circuit that solves the parity
problem when n is equal to 1,
so the input function f is from
1 bit to 1 bit in this case.
What this circuit does is to evaluate the function
f on the inputs 0 and 1 using these two query gates.
It then plugs the two output values it
gets from the query gates into the Boolean circuit from lesson three that computes the XOR,
which is the same thing as the parity.
To be clear, these two
input values right here are not inputs into the problem,
meaning the parity problem,
when we're working with the query model, the input to the problem
is the function f, and you should think about these
two inputs into the circuit
as being hard-coded
values that never change, they're essentially part of the algorithm.
We want to compute the XOR of f 0 and f 1, so we initialized these
two wires in this way
to make it work. We've used two query gates
here, this one and this one,
and so the algorithm represented
by this Boolean circuit makes two queries, and if we think about the
parity problem for a moment
for functions from one bit to one bit, we see that it's absolutely necessary for any Boolean circuit
that solves this problem
to make at least two queries.
If you only make one query so that you only know one
output value of the function f and not the other, you don't actually have
any information at all
about the parity, because the other output value
could equally well be 0 or 1, leading to either of the
two possible solutions
to the problem. So in terms of the number
of queries that it makes, this Boolean circuit is as good as it gets
for the parity problem
when n is equal to 1.